So far from our result faltering,
the United Kingdom is announcing today
our single biggest package of defence say
to Ukraine since the war began.
Worth two and a half billion pounds.
This will include more air defense equipment,
more anti tank weapons,
more long range missiles,
thousands of rounds,
more ammunition and artillery shells, training
for thousands more Ukrainian service men and women
and £200 million to build thousands more drones.
The single largest package of drones given to Ukraine
by any nation.
In total, since the war began,
the UK will have provided
almost £12 billion of aid to Ukraine.
And I'm proud that today
President Zelensky and I
have signed a new security agreement
that will form the core
of a partnership between our two countries
that will last 100 years or more.
Ukraine is not alone.
And Ukraine will never be alone.
Putin might think that he can outlast us,
but he is wrong.
We stand with you today,
tomorrow and for as long as it takes.